bakary traoré merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors le mali
doit désigner aujourd'hui un président
et un premier ministre civil selon
l'ultimatum fixé par la cedeao
or samedi dernier la junte a obtenu une
charte lors des concertations nationales
qui fixe à 18 mois la durée de la
période de transition pour aboutir à des
élections
alors qui croire la cedeao bien la junte
je pense que les conclusions aux délais
renouvelle les conclusions du sommet
extraordinaire des chefs d'état de la
cedeao toute la question du mali
progresse et visant ce que est bien bien
là la chaîne est allé aux négociations
au niveau des dates ideo avec une
position fragile d'autant plus que et
bien cette charte et qui a été adoptée
bad lors des concertations nationales et
bien n'a pas été approuvé par l'ensemble
donc des forces vives de la nation
notamment par le m5 f10 qui a été à la
base donc une au point de contestation
et qui a abouti à la chute du régime
lyon doit car keita je pense que bien la
junte aurait dû et bien travailler
davantage aux russes ou les résultats
donc de ces concertations de faire en
sorte que ça soit validée par l'ensemble
des forces vives de la nation afin de
renforcer sa position ne pourra suite
allait discuter avec la cedeao et je
pense que dans certaines circonstances
et bien sûr au cours de ce sommet il ya
eu deux points qui ont été et notamment
abordé et qui on a résisté donc des
avancées notamment en ce qui concerne et
bien le profil donc le président de la
transition la junte donc amener enfin la
concertation nationalisons ont opposé et
bien une profils soient civils ou
militaires
alors que la vidéo exige et un profil
civile
mais allez l'actuel je pense que la
junte de même accompli que bien on
s'achemine finalement vers septèmes
président de la transition du profil si
lille
donc ce serait ça serait ça le compromis
possible après ce rendez vous entre la
cedeao est là l agence malienne
aujourd'hui tout à fait mais à côté de
ce point de compromis il ya aussi des
gens point de compromis à savoir les
prérogatives selon les prérogatives du
vice président parce qu'il parmi les
organes faut dégager par la charte il ya
donc le président de la tradition vous
avez un vice président de la transition
vous avez un pmu nice un gouvernement un
événement est une conseil national
excepté quelques crochets nationale donc
qui est l'organe législatif
donc au niveau de la vice-présidence la
transistion les prérogatives qui ont été
attribués au vice président donc la
tradition sont vraiment à mon avis est
colossal et saper a mené plusieurs l'un
des mets donc des confusions ou des
crispations voire des empiétements haut
niveau de compétence décès des instances
de la présidence et la vice-présidence
si dans l'optique où le le président de
la transition et des civils et que le
vice président était militaire avec
nantis du bonhomme négatives notamment
la défense sécurité et la question de la
refondation de l'état
eh bien ça à riscle et donc de susciter
des blocages mais toujours point c'est
déjà un point mérite d'être revu mon
avis par la crainte et fument au niveau
national au niveau d'un corps d'une
autre forme enfin forme de rencontres à
faire pour revoir les prérogatives très
importante à mes yeux qui ont été
attribués au vice président alors vous
parlez des questions de sécurité
justement on connaît au mali la
fragilité sécuritaire liés à la présence
jihadistes est ce que c'est cette jia 10
peuvent profiter de la situation selon
vous
a mon avis oui j'ai répondu oui parce
que la situation est telle que
le pays encore dans une position très
fragile d'abord c'était de l'acceptation
était déjà délétère
avant le coup d'état et avec donc cette
situation de renversement du régime et
dans les caddies souhaitons toujours vos
sacs et vous trouvez des bonbonnes six
occasions à mon avis pour rebondir
même s'il faut saluer dans les efforts
déployés ces taxis par les forces armées
maliennes
vous montrez leur avance et certains
membres de l'opposition mais je pense
que la situation est telle que d'amour
tant que cette situation n'est pas d'une
manière générale assez ni au niveau
politique même où le plan sécuritaire
tout reste très fragile en ce moment
merci beaucoup bakary traoré d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste spécialiste du
mali et du sahel